do you have politically diverse friends
what do you talk about with them I'm a
progressive I live in a town full of
progressives and 15 years ago I didn't
have any conservative friends now I have
a wonderful mix of friends and they
include John I am not too progressive
I'm a Republican who grew up in a
Republican family and the conservative
South and even worked in Republican
politics locally and the national level
but last 24 years have been in
technology and living in a very
progressive area so I have a lot of
progressive friends including Joe so I
was born in Berkeley California a
notoriously progressive college town and
I was there now
in 1998 six months into the Monica
Lewinsky Clinton impeachment scandal
I helped co-found moveon.org with a
one-sentence petition Congress must
immediately percenter the President and
move on to pressing issues facing the
nation now that was actually very
unifying petition in many ways you could
love Clinton or Hicklin and agree that
the best thing for the country was to
move on as the leader of move on I saw
the polarization just continue and I
found myself wondering why I saw sling
so differently than many people in other
parts of the country so in 2005 when I
had an opportunity to get together with
grassroots leaders across the political
divide I grabbed it and I became friends
with a lot of people I never had a
chance to talk to you before and that
include leadership in the Christian
Coalition Austin Cena's on the right the
way move on is seen as on the left and
this led to me showing up on Capitol
Hill with one of the Christian Coalition
leaders or my friend
to lobby for net neutrality that was
powerful we turned heads
so this work was transformational for me
and I found myself wondering how can
vast numbers of people have the
opportunity to really connect with
people that have very different views I
was born in Oneida Tennessee ride across
the state border from a small coal
mining town
stern's Kentucky and I lived there for
first few years of my life before moving
to another small town Frankfort Kentucky
basically I grew up in small-town
America
conservative at its heart now it's turns
and Berkeley they're a little different
so in the 90s I moved out out west to a
progressive area to work in technology
worked at Microsoft worked at Netscape
actually became the product manager lead
for a Netscape Navigator the first
popular web browser now in the early
days of the Internet we were just moved
and inspired by a vision when we're
connected to all these different people
around the world and all these different
ideas we'll be able to make great
decisions and we'll be able to
appreciate each other for the beautiful
diversity that the whole world has to
offer I also 20 years ago gave a speech
saying it might not work out that way
that we might actually be trained to
discriminate against each other in new
ways so what happened it's not like we
just woke up one day and decide to hate
each other more here's what happened
there's just too much noise too many
people too many ideas so we use
technology to filter it out a little bit
and what happens it lets in ideas I
already agree with and lets in the
popular ideas a--let's and people just
like me who think just like me that
sounds kind of good right well not
necessarily because two very scary
things happen when we have such narrow
worldviews first we become more extreme
in our beliefs second we become less
tolerant of anybody who's different than
we are
this sounds familiar
does this sound like modern America the
modern world well the good news is that
technology is changing
and it could change for the better and
that's the fact why I started all sides
calm to create technologies and services
to free us from these filter bubbles the
very first thing we did was create
technology that identifies bias so we
could show different perspectives side
by side to free us from the filter
bubbles of news media and then I met
Joan
so I met John outside of Washington DC
with a idealist a group of cross
partisans bridge builders and we wanted
to reweave the fabric of our communities
we believe that our differences can be a
strength that our values can be
complimentary and that we have to
overcome the fight so that we can honor
everyone's values and not lose any of
our own I went for this wonderful walk
with John where I started learning about
the work he was doing to pierce the
filter bubble it was powerful it's
brilliant
you know living in separate narratives
is not good we can't even have a
conversation or do collaborative
problem-solving when we don't share the
same facts so one thing to take away
from today is if John blades asked you
to go on a walk go on that walk it
changed it so it really changed the way
I was thinking about things to free
ourselves in the filter bubbles we can't
just think about information filter
bubbles but also relationship and social
filter bubbles you see we human beings
we're not nearly as smart as we think we
are we don't generally make decisions
intellectually we make them emotional
intuitively and then we use our big old
brains to rationalize anything we want
to rationalize we're not really like
Vulcans like mr. Spock we're more like
bold Cowboys like Captain Kirk or
passionate idealist like dr. McCoy okay
for those y'all who prefer the new Star
Trek crew here you go
don't forget the strong woman come on
strong women okay all right John and I
are both Star Trek fans what's not to
love about a future with that kind of
optimism and having a good future in
mind is a big deal very important
and understanding what the problem is
very important but we have to do
something so what do we do it's actually
not that hard we had to add diversity to
our lives now it's just information but
relationship diversity and by diversity
I mean Big D diversity not just racial
and gender which are very important but
also diversity of age like young and old
rural and urban liberal and conservative
in the u.s. Democrat and Republican now
in a great example so somebody freeing
themselves from the filter bubbles and
getting a more diverse life is once
again next to me Joan so the question is
who among you has had relationships lost
or harm due to differences in politics
religion or whatever raise your hands
yeah this year I have talked to so many
people that have experienced that kind
of loss people here have seen tears well
up in people's eyes as they talk about
family members from whom they're
estranged living room conversations were
designed to begin to heal political and
personal differences they're simple
conversations where two friends with
different viewpoints each invite two
friends for structured conversation with
everyone's agreed to some simple ground
rules
curiosity listening respect taking turns
everything we learned in kindergarten
right really easy so that by the time
you're talking about the topic you've
agreed to talk about you actually have a
census you know I kind of like this
person and you listen to each other
differently that's kind of a human
condition listen differently to people
we care about and then there's
reflection and possibly next steps this
is a deep listening practice it's never
a debate and that's incredibly powerful
these conversations in our own living
rooms with people who have different
viewpoints are an incredible adventure
we just
govern respect and even love people that
are different from us and it's powerful
so what are you curious about what's the
conversation you yearn to have let's do
this together together yes
[Applause]
[Music]